yes it's like it's like this go big or
go home
tell me what do you want to get to like
what's your what's your you got an
ultimate goal in real estate like you
want to be doing what you're doing now
when do you retire don't you want to
[ __ ] sit back
and just be like telling this guy yeah i
got i wanted my goals changed by the
minute
so sometimes it's like bro you know i
want to do this i want to do i want to
do the third but in reality what i
realized was what is your
ultimate [ __ ] like the the most in
the perfect world
like what is the perfect day look like
for you like if you could do whatever
the [ __ ] you wanted and money didn't
matter if i tell you this i know you're
gonna say you're nuts
my ultimate goal is to bet everything on
black in the bro that table and lose it
all
oh yeah grind back be dead bro and do it
again i got i got underwears
i got a bvd t-shirt and i got a pair of
chocolates
why do a lot of people say that though
because the grind is the thrill daddy
you want to have the because look what
am i going to tell you i want to buy
i want to buy the taj mahal and and and
and have
golden condoms who gives a [ __ ] about
that that's
that's like you cashed in your chips you
sold the dream yeah you're out the box
yeah you're not interested in that hell
no hell no
that's whack a lot of people say a lot
of people that chase
chase the money spend a lot of time like
grinding and trying to climb the ladder
over a long period of time
chasing money forever and when they
eventually make it they feel like when
they get to the top
when they get to the top of the mountain
when they've achieved what they thought
was their goal
when they earned when they earned their
first couple million they finally be
like okay wow
i finally got more money than i ever
thought i would have
nowhere near what i thought it would be
it's not it's not what
it was it was made out to be it's not
i'm at the top i'm at the top the quote
top but it's
so i'm gonna put a two like this repeat
this so
you remember nas came out with ilmatic
in 93
he had five mics on the source in one of
the songs he's like
yo i want a hundred g's in a link that
was his goal
a hundred thousand dollars in a link bro
he
look at him now he's that just walking
in a room
the point is your goals change as the
days change
you you see a goal it's like bro i want
that but in reality
monetary value has no value the only
thing that really has value
is your memories [ __ ] a monetary [ __ ]
money [ __ ] bread [ __ ] the dream it's
about what you can remember
who you roll with what what can you talk
about how i could school you to get it
you dead broke you want to get how can i
make you eat how can i make you better
like my barber d barber ill [ __ ]
came out the block with nothing
got mad kids illest barber in town and
all he wants to do is help everybody
why because when you are that dude and
when you know what time it is
helping somebody get it and knowing that
you got them there
that has more value than money cause
think about we're going to eat steaks at
bowls and moe's over here
go to um where where am i going monty
carlo
like what's hot like straight up and
down where you going yeah bro there's a
lot of uh
there's a really good feeling in giving
[ __ ] to people and making other people
you know what i mean like giving [ __ ]
away
to somebody else it's not like that bill
gates just throwing money in the trash
it's like this crying to get it let me
school you how to get it let me show you
how to get it
wake up like peak diddy remember yeah
that show go get me some um
go to nickabaca avenue and get me and
get me a pastrami
go walk like why am i gonna walk why
because we gotta see if you're dedicated
remember the last time i told you when i
came here i was a janitor in brandon
high school
walk four miles to work for six dollars
an hour why because you gotta get it
you have to understand how bad you need
it
how bad you want it what you're willing
to do you have to cry
mentally with the next [ __ ]
that's nastier than you
get it yeah because if this dude wants
my money
i gotta bang with him physically or
mentally and i'm not gonna lose too many
mental battles
so now i gotta fight you getting a lot
of fights
not really no more i'm an old school
dude
i'm in the boxing gym three days a week
what do i need to fight for i'm gonna
catch a bit ain't gonna sue me
i'm not beat for that right this is not
the old days
when we could knuckle up and shake hands
later mm-hmm we're not with that no more
we are lawsuits now yeah everybody's
[ __ ] suing now bro
bro the game has changed the world has
changed everybody like trying to get it
i'm telling you daddy the way to get
this bread is to show people how to make
money
how can we get a daisy chain because if
you bring let me tell you how it is
let's say you bring me 30 heads right 30
heads of what
30 people you bring me 30 people feel me
we talk about
what does that mean jesus is like heads
of cabbage heads up
i'm talking about 30 heads dog 30 people
and i scoot and put them in the room
look this is how we're going to get it
this is how we're going to do it you're
going to highlight my man and i'm going
to school him
so he can school you then you're going
to call me on the deal it's like it's
like a
a big you remember that movie um we're
like at a basement what's it called um
damn and it's like they're selling penny
stocks wolf of wall street
no before that before that whatever
boiler room boiler room yeah yeah it's
like this
but instead of selling dreams we're
selling reality
because i'm not trying to rob nobody i'm
trying to stick them for their crib at
the right number
no straight up you feel me does that
make sense yeah it makes sense
no because a little no no straight up
here cause i'm telling you what time it
is
cause look if you guys 1968 it's as
honest as it gets
if you go into your crib and you see a
1970s
couch where the [ __ ] is that chick from
what's the name of that that
i got that [ __ ] for free no i
get it
but i'm saying you you got you got um
laminate wood on the doors
how many [ __ ] you think been [ __ ]
on that couch ah yeah like how many
100 in this thing the better question is
how many ticks you smashed
then who cares that has no value so the
point is like i told you the memory
but reality is you got to school people
in the hustle
the game and you got to put them so we
could get bread that's the name of the
game
but do it for free so you could eat
everybody eats everybody happy
once you start charging for classes
you're already trying to stick them
because if you pay me i got no faith in
you
so what's your goal what's your goal for
getting in the online game why do you
want to create a following online why do
you want to be on social media because
you know what it is
i know a lot of people and i deal with a
lot of people and i feel guilty i'm not
spitting my game to everybody
i want everybody to know what time it is
with me i want everybody to bang with me
question me
give me the dirtiest question give me
the nap if you yo straight up
if you gave me a nice comment i love you
you know who joey diaz is
joey diaz holy [ __ ] aiden pull up a
video of joey diaz or show me who he
probably grew up next to that guy
i feel like you actually do where is he
from i think you know this i think he's
from jersey
where we're at comedian i'm not sure
we're about to show you bro
i think you and this guy would really
get a little oh yeah you're right
he's a big he does a lot of coke he
smokes a lot of weeds
everybody does coke he just does he
tells stories he don't do none of that
stuff anymore i don't do cocaine cause
i'm not trying to have a heart attack i
got natural energy
yeah you got plenty i don't i don't like
to smoke weed because i get fatter and
hungrier
you feel me i'm not saying i never smoke
weed uh click on his channel
you gotta find his his uh click on
videos clip on put on his clips from
like joe wrote oh she's like a honey
no bro he's like probably in his 50s
late 50s 60s maybe
find one of his videos where he's
talking to his phone
uh what's his what's his [ __ ] thing
called where every morning just go to
joey diaz like highlights and pull up a
highlight rail
type in highlights after his name you
think we're boring people right now
hell no bro because we were looking for
joey diaz
that's okay that's okay yo just light up
a stoke dog
is this an airport no bro i'll get
kicked out no way
yeah bro if i'm smoking speech people
get so [ __ ] pissed bro
foreign